Vous savez vraiment
ce que c’est,
la LOGIQUE ?
La logique,
c’est la connexion NATURELLE
entre les choses.
Si des choses sont connectées LOGIQUEMENT,
ça veut dire qu’elles s’enchaînent
RÉGULIÈREMENT
et NÉCESSAIREMENT.
Par exemple,
si je couvre mon œil avec ma main,
je ne vois plus de cet œil.
L’action de poser ma main
sur mon œil
entraîne À CHAQUE FOIS,
et SANS EXCEPTION POSSIBLE,
l’incapacité de l’œil.
Il existe donc un lien LOGIQUE
entre les deux.
Ce type de liens est TRÈS IMPORTANT
en dissertation,
parce que ce sont
CES LIENS
qui permettent de passer
RIGOUREUSEMENT
d’une idée
à une autre,
c’est-à-dire de faire AVANCER
la réflexion.
Dans l’absolu,
les connecteurs logiques sont la marque
d’un MAUVAIS style.
Oui,
parce que les critiques littéraires considèrent
que l’enchaînement des idées
doit être NATUREL
AU POINT
qu’il n’ait pas besoin
d’être renforcé artificiellement.
Dit plus simplement,
si on exprime ses idées clairement,
alors le lecteur comprendra FACILEMENT
les connexions LOGIQUES
qui existent entre elles.
MAIS BON,
tout le monde n’est pas d’accord
avec les critiques littéraires
— et puis les études expérimentales sur
la lecture
montrent que les lecteurs PRÉFÈRENT
les textes AVEC
des liens logiques.
MAIS SURTOUT,
si les connecteurs logiques
sont la marque d’un mauvais style,
c’est DANS L’ABSOLU.
Or,
une dissertation,
ce n’est pas n’importe quel texte
— ce n’est pas un roman,
ni un article.
Vous le savez peut-être déjà :
le correcteur va vous lire
TRÈS RAPIDEMENT.
Les qualités de votre rédaction
doivent donc être GROSSIÈRES
afin qu’elles sautent aux yeux
lors d’une lecture EXPÉDITIVE.
Et dans cette perspective,
les connecteurs logiques
sont TRÈS UTILES,
parce qu’ils servent à DÉCUPLER
l’impression de cohérence
de votre propos
— c’est-à-dire que
s’il y a beaucoup de liens logiques
dans votre dissertation,
le correcteur aura l’impression
que vos idées s’enchaînent bien.
Vous avez donc INTÉRÊT
à utiliser beaucoup de connecteurs logiques
en dissertation.
Ce n’est donc pas étonnant
qu’il y en ait plein
dans les bonnes copies.
Mais si vous voulez être capable
de rédiger une BONNE dissertation,
vous avez d’abord besoin
d’une BONNE méthode.
Eh bien,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
inscrivez-vous
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
mais vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans le description de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pourrez le découvrir plus tard,
à la fin de cette vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours.
LÀ TOUT DE SUITE,
restez concentré sur cette vidéo,
regardez-la attentivement
jusqu’au bout,
et vous saurez COMMENT
utiliser les connecteurs logiques en dissertation.
Vous pourrez séduire le correcteur,
et gagner FACILEMENT des points,
DÈS votre prochaine dissertation.
Je vous l’ai dit :
les connecteurs logiques servent à créer
une GROSSIÈRE
impression de cohérence
en dissertation.
Mais dans le détail,
il y a différentes manières
de le faire.
SUR LE FOND,
tout d’abord,
vous devez distinguer
DEUX TYPES
de connexion logique.
Une connexion peut LIER
deux idées,
mais elle peut aussi servir à DÉVELOPPER
une idée,
c’est-à-dire à fournir des informations
PLUS PRÉCISES
que votre esprit peut ranger
dans l’idée
PLUS GÉNÉRALE.
Alors,
je pourrais continuer
à vous en parler
— parce que c’est un sujet qui me passionne,
la manipulation des idées —
MAIS ça va devenir compliqué,
et ça ne sera pas rentable POUR VOUS,
c’est-à-dire que ce n’est pas grâce
à ça
qui vous allez rapidement gagner des points
en dissertation.
Donc rappelez-vous simplement
que SUR LE FOND,
un lien logique peut servir
soit À LIER deux idées,
soit à DÉVELOPPER une idée.
Maintenant,
quel est le rôle des connecteurs logiques
du point de vue DE LA FORME ?
Un lien logique peut tout d’abord
servir à connecter deux propositions
dans une MÊME phrase.
Par exemple :
« Je m’entraîne à la salle de sport
BIEN QUE
je n’aie pas dormi de la nuit.
»
Dans cette phrase,
la conjonction de subordination « BIEN QUE
»
exprime l’OPPOSITION
entre le fait de s’entraîner à la salle
de sport,
et celui de ne pas avoir dormi de la nuit
— parce qu’après une insomnie,
on n’a pas beaucoup d’énergie
(je parle d’expérience).
Donc un lien logique peut connecter deux propositions
dans une MÊME PHRASE.
MAIS il peut aussi connecter
deux phrases COMPLÈTES.
Par exemple :
« Je suis très fatigué en raison d’une
insomnie.
Je m’entraîne TOUT DE MÊME
à la salle de sport.
»
Dans ce cas,
c’est la locution adverbiale
de la seconde phrase
« TOUT DE MÊME »
qui exprime l’opposition
entre l’effort de s’entraîner à la salle
de sport
et l’insomnie.
Alors,
vous avez intérêt à utiliser les connecteurs
logiques
à la fois À L’INTÉRIEUR
et ENTRE les phrases,
mais LA PRIORITÉ
c’est de lier les phrases entre elles,
parce que ça facilite
la lecture du correcteur.
En termes de fréquence,
je vous recommande d’utiliser
UN connecteur logique
PAR PHRASE,
et DE VARIER
sa place dans la phrase :
un coup au début,
au coup au milieu.
Sans cette variation,
le rythme de vos phrases sera haché
et monotone.
Regardez ces deux phrases :
« EN EFFET,
je suis fatigué en raison d’une insomnie.
POURTANT,
je m’entraîne à la salle de sport.
»
Pour améliorer le rythme,
il suffit de déporter l’adverbe « POURTANT
»
AU MILIEU
de la seconde phrase.
Ça donne :
« En effet,
je suis fatigué en raison d’une insomnie.
Je m’entraîne POURTANT
à la salle de sport.
»
Alors je suis d’accord,
c’est un détail
— mais lorsqu’ils s’accumulent,
les détails commencent à peser,
et puis,
comme vous le savez,
la clarté de l’expression écrite
est SURVALORISÉE
en dissertation.
Voilà,
maintenant que vous connaissez
les DEUX RÔLES
des liens logiques en dissertation,
je vais vous montrer les connecteurs
que vous pouvez utiliser.
Je commence par le PREMIER TYPE
de connecteur logique,
ceux qui LIENT deux idées.
Si vous voulez LIER deux idées,
vous avez à votre disposition
CINQ types principaux
de connecteurs logiques.
Le premier type,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques d’OPPOSITION.
Je ne vais pas les énumérer ;
vous pouvez voir une liste indicative
à l’écran.
Les liens logiques d’opposition sont
LES PLUS UTILES
en dissertation
parce que l’opposition est LA NATURE MÊME
de la tension dialectique.
En effet,
pour que la réflexion soit fructueuse,
il faut penser
CONTRE SOI-MÊME.
Vous aurez donc tout particulièrement besoin
des liens logiques d’opposition
dans L’ANNONCE DE PLAN,
puisque les grandes parties du plan de la
dissertation
sont articulées logiquement.
Le DEUXIÈME type de connecteur logique
qui sert à connecter deux idées,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques de CAUSE.
Ce type de connecteurs logiques est également
très utile en dissertation.
Parce que comme le dit Rousseau,
la résolution de tout problème commence
par la recherche
DES CAUSES.
Moi j’utilise surtout
les liens logiques de cause suivants :
Le TROISIÈME type,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques de CONSÉQUENCE.
La conséquence est,
elle aussi,
importante
parce qu’elle constitue
l’INVERSE logique
de la cause.
Si A est la CAUSE de B,
alors B est la CONSÉQUENCE
de A.
J’aime bien
les connecteurs logiques de conséquence suivants
:
Le QUATRIÈME type de connecteur logique
qui sert à connecter deux idées,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques d’ADDITION.
Alors,
l’addition c’est pas super
comme lien logique,
parce qu’elle n’est pas vraiment « LOGIQUE
»
au sens strict :
deux idées additionnées ne sont pas
INTRINSÈQUEMENT CONNECTÉES.
Moi je préfère
les liens logiques d’addition suivants :
Essayez de ne pas trop utiliser ces liens,
parce qu’ils peuvent donner l’impression
au correcteur
que vous « empilez » les idées,
plutôt que de les connecter
LOGIQUEMENT.
Enfin,
le CINQUIÈME type de connecteur logique
qui sert à connecter deux idées,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques
de CONCLUSION.
Ils sont moins utiles
que les précédents,
MAIS ils servent quand même,
parce que si vous exposez votre réflexion
avec MÉTHODE,
alors vous devez résumer
les RÉSULTATS
de votre réflexion
à différentes étapes
— typiquement,
à la fin d’un paragraphe,
ou dans une conclusion partielle.
Voici les liens logiques de conclusion
que j’utilise :
Voilà,
vous connaissez maintenant les CINQ
connecteurs logiques qui servent
à LIER
deux idées :
les liens logiques d’OPPOSITION,
de CAUSE,
de CONSÉQUENCE,
d’ADDITION,
et enfin
de CONCLUSION.
Maintenant je vais vous parler
des connecteurs logiques qui servent
à DÉVELOPPER une idée.
Pour commencer,
je vous rappelle
que DÉVELOPPER
une idée,
ça signifie fournir des informations
PLUS PRÉCISES
qui sont en rapport avec l’idée.
D’accord ?
Pour faire ça,
vous pouvez utiliser TROIS TYPES
de connecteurs logiques.
Le PREMIER type,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques
de PRÉCISION.
Ce type de connecteurs logiques
me sert surtout à indiquer
que la phrase a pour fonction
de CREUSER
l’idée
de la précédente.
Je les utilise donc davantage
À L’INTÉRIEUR
des paragraphes.
Je préfère les liens logiques de précision
suivants :
Le DEUXIÈME type de connecteurs logiques
qui sert à développer une idée,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques
d’ÉNUMÉRATION.
Alors,
comme les élèves les connaissent moins,
je vous donne un exemple :
« Ma méthode de dissertation
comporte sept étapes.
EN PREMIER LIEU,
je réfléchis au sujet
de manière stratégique.
Je cherche ensuite des exemples
pour en délimiter le champ… »
Je me sers surtout
des connecteurs logiques d’énumération
pour rédiger les introductions partielles
et les premières phrases
des paragraphes.
En effet,
c’est une solution SIMPLE
pour indiquer au correcteur
OÙ il se situe
dans la progression de la réflexion.
En pratique,
vous devez d’abord présenter
la première idée du développement
avec un des liens suivants :
Ensuite,
vous énumérez les idées suivantes
avec les AUTRES TYPES
de connecteurs logiques.
Enfin,
le TROISIÈME type de lien logique
qui sert à développer une idée,
ce sont les connecteurs logiques
d’ILLUSTRATION.
Ce type de connecteurs logiques
sert généralement
à passer du niveau ABSTRAIT
au niveau CONCRET.
Ils sont donc particulièrement utiles
À L’INTÉRIEUR
des paragraphes.
J’utilise en priorité
les liens logiques d’illustration suivants
:
Voilà,
vous connaissez maintenant
les TROIS TYPES
de liens logiques
qui servent à DÉVELOPPER
une idée :
les connecteurs logiques
de PRÉCISION,
d’ÉNUMÉRATION,
et enfin
d’ILLUSTRATION.
Vous savez maintenant COMMENT
utiliser les connecteurs logiques
en dissertation.
LOGIQUEMENT,
la prochaine étape de cette vidéo,
c’est…
la conclusion.
Alors,
comme dans une bonne dissertation,
je vais vous rappeler
ce que vous avez appris
dans cette vidéo.
En résumé,
vous avez appris TROIS CHOSES :
la PREMIÈRE chose,
c’est que SUR LE FOND,
les connecteurs logiques servent
soit à LIER
deux idées,
soit à DÉVELOPPER
une idée,
et que SUR LA FORME,
vous pouvez les utiliser
soit À L’INTÉRIEUR
d’une MÊME phrase
pour connecter deux propositions,
soit pour connecter
DEUX phrases DIFFÉRENTES ;
la DEUXIÈME chose
que vous avez apprise
dans cette vidéo,
ce sont les CINQ TYPES
de connecteurs logiques
qui servent À LIER
deux idées :
les liens logiques d’OPPOSITION,
de CAUSE,
de CONSÉQUENCE,
d’ADDITION,
et enfin
de CONCLUSION ;
et enfin,
la TROISIÈME chose
que vous avez apprise,
ce sont les TROIS TYPES
de connecteurs logiques qui servent
À DÉVELOPPER
une idée :
les connecteurs logiques
de PRÉCISION,
d’ÉNUMÉRATION,
et enfin
d’ILLUSTRATION.
Si vous suivez les conseils que je vous ai
donnés
dans cette vidéo,
vous vous améliorerez
en dissertation,
MAIS vous savez bien
que les connecteurs logiques,
ça reste UN DÉTAIL
— ce n’est pas L’ESSENTIEL
pour réussir une dissertation.
Ce qui est ESSENTIEL,
c’est d’avoir une méthodologie SOLIDE.
Je vous invite donc
à vous inscrire pour recevoir
mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et puis qu’elle vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour utiliser EFFICACEMENT
les connecteurs logiques
en dissertation.